the Tony award-winning director numerous
Broadway hits including Raisin in the
Sun fences and the mountaintop I've seen
them all
his most recent Broadway production
children of a lesser God is nominated
for a Tony throughout his decades-long
career Leone's work focused on diversity
inclusion and influencing social change
in his new memoir take you wherever you
go
interesting title Leon writes about his
humble beginnings growing up in
Tallahassee Florida with his grandmother
Kenny Leon joins us at the table do we
call you
handsome Lion King your name means
Kenneth means handsome Leon means lion
or Leroy means King that's right so
listen we shot told ya handsome lion or
mr. Leon but when you sat down Norris
said you win the prize for best shoes at
the table we should get a shot of those
shoes and once again it leads to a story
about your grandmother because your
grandmother said to you what she said
take you wherever you go and I wear
these shoes to remember her yeah because
they should remind me to stay grounded
and remember that you just a country boy
from Tallahassee Florida who grew up in
st. Petersburg yeah your grandmother
made me write about her and your mom
auntie Ruth had a big big big influence
on your life
Momo's grandmothers and mothers do but
this seemed especially close for you to
me absolutely my grandmother had 13
children well so I felt like I was her
14th after her kids were out of the
house and I had the fortune of living
with her the early early years of my
life you know so we would sit out in the
country of Tallahassee Florida go on a
small farm and watch cars go by like
that's my car
that's your car and those are great
times and then I later went to live with
my mother and stepfather in st.
Petersburg Florida how did that lead you
to Broadway yeah from Miccosukee road to
Broadway I don't know it's something
that she said she said baby take you
wherever you go what you're talking
about that means you got a you got a
better chance at being yourself yeah you
know everybody else has taken so be
yourself so I think I've gotten to where
I am now because I'm authentic Lee Kenny
Leon I'm not like anyone else you know
when I work with Denzel or Sam Jackson I
think they like it
because I'm my raw authentic self if
something is not working hey man that's
not working and they test you they test
your trust and so yeah what what happens
though when you're being your raw
authentic self and you're out there and
an actor and then suddenly somebody
tells you you know you shouldn't be an
actor you should be a director what was
that moment like I mean you're being
yourself you're doing the right thing
right yeah my boss Frank would tell you
said I couldn't direct you know he said
I was a wonderful actor he wanted me to
act but I knew in my heart God had
blessed me to direct and so in order to
keep the love with Frank I had to say I
love you but I got to move and I found
out that in life every 7 to 10 years you
have to change and do something else and
you can't be jobs change jobs you can't
be a prisoner of what you're doing and
so when I left that Acting Company it
allowed me to go off into the world to
become a director when I left the
Alliance theater it allowed me to leave
that theater and then become a Broadway
director so every 7 to 10 years you
should leave and you know you step into
yourself you also talk about life
lessons that it's important to know what
you don't know and find that out be
observant and be open to the answers
that come your way
right I when I did hairspray live that
was after I did the Wiz life hairspray
live had 800 crew people 800 Wow that we
had never done a live musical like that
I didn't know what I was doing but I had
to step into it I had to believe into it
I had to admit what I didn't do and what
I didn't know and because I did that I
was able to pull off something that I
think was really wonderfully done you're
you're the current play you're working
on children of a lesser God is about a
deaf student and her teacher what did
you learn from directing that I I
learned how stupid I was
Lauren writ love was now nominated for a
Tony Award she hadn't ever acted before
and she was teaching me sign language
and after year of sign language with her
I said whoa maybe you could be this
person and I cast her in a first
Broadway show so the fact that she's in
a first Broadway show and now she's
nominated for a Tony Award which is
coming up Sunday August Wilson and
August Wilson and Sam Jackson are big
mentors of yours Sam guys is no longer
with us of course Sam Jackson is the
best from Dave
one I could always call him hey man
should I do this should I do that and
he's always been a person that reminded
me that I'm from the south and that in
the South grown folks get up and go to
work and and he said find your passion
and figure out a way to get paid for it
and that's what we've done and hopefully
I can continue to make my mother and my
grandmother happy by taking me wherever
I go and as I leave my hotel room every
day I say my prayers I said God I want
to take you wherever I go today I hope I
bought a good spiritual feeling here
today and I hope you guys go out it's
nice the some of the sentiment of that's
nice take you wherever you really is
good luck on Sunday thank you thank you
so much Tony's our Sunday you know take
you wherever you go is available
tomorrow wherever you like to buy your
books at Tony's as you heard Kenny say
where this Sunday night at 8/7 central
right here on CBS yeah